i got some stories about mike you know i
just got some stories about my people
people don't know this [__] i got some
stories about mike right no noticing
all right i guess the story's about like
probably they probably
remember this [__] right here i just see
mike all the time and um caesar's palace
right
this [__] loves the shop right
you know i was surprised he didn't try
one of these beautiful rolls royces in
the [__]
damn surprise he didn't drive the
[__] out there right
[Music]
here we go what's up everybody welcome
to another episode of hot box and i'm
evan britten and i'm mike tyson and mike
we got a [__] great guest bro we got
a god in here
today a god a god we definitely do
god you mean moses dennis there's god
right there that's god right there
yeah that's all good baby
welcome brother we've got our brother
chuck in the house as well hey chucky
um well let me just kick this off while
you're lighting your cigar dennis
i have to say as a young kid watching
basketball with my dad
he'd say look at this guy dennis rodman
he's a [__]
a beast on the court he's always getting
the boards
and i looked at you and you know
you were the most different looking dude
out there
colored hair tats yes
dude but i have to say you were a huge
inspiration for me
and i really appreciate who you were who
you are in sports
and it's great to have you here thank
you man yeah
what's the gun though huh el segundo man
newport
mike tyson big time neighbor right yes
oh yeah oh yeah well you're a pelican
hill yes i am now i'm moving over there
yes you should i'm in newport coast i'm
going to go to the coast of that
across the street hell man why you been
mike i'm doing good danny
dennis you know all of us in here really
love you right oh it's cool man
hey man we all love you that's your
whole motto right
keep it love baby keep it love love is
the essence of life yeah it is man you
know
the one thing i like about mike tyson
when he came up from like
15 16 years old man i think we uh our
life is so parallel
you know as far as how we can been
brought up and stuff like that
that's amazing that we really didn't
have any guidance any direction as far
as like we just want to do our
profession
pretty much you know we pretty much
green behind the ears
but uh um when you meet good people
in the beginning in the beginning that's
putting you in that right direction the
right mode
to do something very well that's very
it's very heartfelt
because once once you've been abandoned
when you're like a youth
like between 12 13 14 years old you feel
like that you're lost
then um you have one direction go to
jail like two directions go to jail
or die pretty much because you're in
that [__] environment right
so we're in the same thing i lived in
south oak cliff east dallas
you know rough neighborhood mike you
grew up where brownfield brooklyn that's
kind of [__] nuts huh yeah
you know you got to [__] imagine
that's what i'm saying though
and people don't realize that but you
know what today's social media
instagram it gives a outlet to guys like
me and mike
to really show people and express the
world the fact that you know what
what we did back then kids don't
understand
because everything is so easy so like
complimentary to them now
everything's hanging on a silver platter
if you realize
living like that it's a [__] and then
all of a sudden
come over the mountaintop and all of a
sudden it's still shining baby
and we're living and we're giving
inspiration to the world now
and i was saying that the fact that
it's very difficult to live life playing
sports today
and try to be a parent
that's difficult might know what i'm
saying and i love the fact we needed
that interview
i don't know what i think was it vegas
house whatever and you really showed the
world the fact that
that human side about you i love that
interview i
i paid attention to it because that
came to me because with his kids
i realized what he was going through and
all the trials and tribulations through
marriages and stuff like that
i wasn't that same [__] man i'm still
doing that today but i'm trying to get
my head together
and keep myself focused because i got a
lot of life to live
just like you mike and we we on that
same [__] board right there brother
i'm trying to fight to try to love my
kids and and back then i didn't give a
[__] about
anybody it was all about me me me and
that sucked
and now that's how we look the people
that we love like say custom out he's so
that's what he told me self-preservation
right over everything over my children
everything you you are more important
than everything your children your wife
you you take care of you and that's what
i was taught none of this can work
without you
so you have to take care of you that was
all i put in my mind right
self-preservation he was dying i have to
take care of me
and all the photos to work for for you
to take care of camille photo you get
hold
keep the house you have to take care of
you and that was put in my mind
i became a megalomaniac it was all about
me
you know and that and that stand-up
thing he's doing
i mean that's that's powerful man that's
very powerful
and it's more like it's more like a it's
more like
rembrandt da vinci you know
steve jobs all these guys are so iconic
and they died but you know that the
whole uh
vision about how life should be taught
learned and listened to people don't
realize that until you go through this
[__] man
people don't realize that [__] man it's
like mike tyson has a
has a a god sense of what he wants the
world to know
and the sad thing about it he saw those
heads
at ron rushmore that's one
that's one right there that's one right
there that's word right there let me
just say right there i i'd give it up
michael jordan the guys like that oh man
i mean
everlasting man you know everlasting no
doubt man
no but you gotta always see you talk
about stuff like you got to keep
yourself credit you know
if they play basketball differently
because of people like you
they don't even play with the same rules
no more because of rodman and his crew
when he played with detroit you know
they changed of course you know right
yeah he changed all the rules
you better not even accidentally sweat
on somebody now in basketball yeah
yeah all right for real right now you
guys couldn't have even played
that then that's just what goes into my
hand he holds that
you [__] [__]
is even worse because you can't even
touch the [__] quad she can't do
[__] right listen but look that's why i
respect michael jordan y'all beat that
[__]
he was man he couldn't do nothing you
just kept beating his ass
beating it that's beating her there and
that's why i called him because because
i don't think they could take that ass
whooping
no those guys are beautiful shots again
they probably could score more than
michael because nobody
that beautiful michael's a mean tough
[__] yeah
right whoa right he takes oh
he takes it and give it do you think
lebron would be the same player no
yeah no [__] i don't think so because he
he wasn't brought up that way
yeah so interesting man he wasn't
brought up that way you know how it is
right
yeah so it's all good you know like yeah
it's like you know it's it's amazing
when you when you have that
fire for any sport yeah any sport
and and people should realize the fact
that
i had that that desire to win to win
i didn't give a [__] what it took i'll
do the dirty work i don't give a [__]
you know at the end of the day that ring
is more important because once you get
that ring
we all good we all good and
for mike when he came up he had one
thing doing
i'm going i didn't beat your ass and do
my job that's what i'm trying to do
stuff like that
so basically you know guess what it
wasn't about the [__] money for me i
know it went about the money in the
beginning for him
it was but it was like he's gonna do his
job i did my job
i always say you know um when i was 25
years old when i came in the league i
said
i don't give a [__] i'll play for a
[__] dollar i just want to play
you know it didn't matter to me and then
the same thing when i look at his career
i look at that [__] man he just went out
and said [__] it you know this is my job
this is what i'm going
i'm going to do this okay great because
the motto can't just be a knockout
you got to be a spectacular knockout
right you're right right devastating
no don't let me knock somebody out and
it wasn't to his liking
i'm not getting no love even if it was a
knock on the but the police went
mad right it wasn't like in the world it
should be done it was [__]
garbage it sounds like chokes either
don't talk to me
we be in the car we just driving in the
car no one's saying [__]
yeah it's interesting but him right
you know yeah just bring it up all right
no [__] right chuck zero just knocked
[__] out for it for free
no he never did a freak you never did it
for free with all the readings
[Music]
on the [__] [__] there was
definitely a reason
right well but that's why i'm
responsible for more blackouts than khan
edison
oh this guy got jokes over here shaking
come on man i saw some [__] monk
what's in the mongols right the
motorcycle bank
bag i saw something i took some pictures
i was thinking about chuck
recently probably a year ago
is it the same now chuck is is uh
the motorcycle gang world is it the same
as it was when you were
coming up motorcycle club world it's not
a gang
they're still killing people yeah it's
different
i mean it's uh you know i'm at a club 15
years now
but when i was a you know 25 year member
was a lot different
a lot different do you think it's more
hostile or do you think it's more
serene well it's more laid-back now
really so that yeah absolutely
because i remember located in the 70s
and 80s they were big especially in
quebec when i started going to quebec
and stuff montreal it was big up there
yeah they're still big up there
yeah you know it's still big up here but
back in like you said in the 70s and 80s
it was a
different time than today
well you guys all know each other you
guys have met as well we got some
stories i got some stories about mike
you know i just
got some stories about my people people
don't know this [__] i got some stories
about mike right no notice you know
remember this [__] right here i just see
mike all the time
and i'm in um caesar's palace right this
[__] loves the shop right
you know you know i'm surprised he
didn't drive one his uh beautiful rolls
royces in the [__]
surprise he didn't try the [__]
out there right he'd buy tigers and i
don't know monkeys and birds and [__]
like that so
you know his fortunes are [__]
immaculate he was more like uh
what's that uh that uh um the show in
vegas at the mirage
oh uh sig freedom roar that was him that
was yeah he was a black version right
he said he was the black person right
there in his house we're like god damn
it mike
[__] who is this okay great so yeah
mike was uh i used to go to vegas all
the time see mike mike was throwing him
like
a thousand [__] you're just you
know hanging out you know mike his mic
you know so
one day one day i'm out at the pool at
the uh at the mirage you know and the
hard rock
so i said okay let's go to goddamn
season spot let's go shopping okay
so go to the mall we're walking down you
know in the facades
and then i decided to go in the versace
you know versace versace right you know
i'm buying [__] for no [__] reason
so i walk in there so you know mike
tyson's here right so i agree so anyway
so
they told everybody to get the [__] out
mike tyson said shopping you know they
didn't give a [__] about me i was nobody
so that's true story so i go in and they
lock the door and it's me and mike and i
and people
you know doing that thing so mice are
now getting fitted for suits
this is a scene you know and uh so it's
me and my my friend
that one of my other friends me and this
little white guy class named doug
mcallister
so i go to mike i said mike what's going
on man man mike broke bread a little bit
the next thing you know i walk away get
fitted for you know some suits or
whatever
and my friend had this great idea to go
with the mic right
remember this [__] right so you guys had
this great idea well watch me go up to
mike i said boy he's right over there
right
so he walks to the mic and he went and
he said hey mike how are you doing
mike turns around and mike would you
know what he won't like this but
it actually happened so my turn my turns
around
and my friend went up to him and
literally slapped him in the face
and now not hard but just more like like
that
and mike turned around came straight to
me and said dennis
i love you to death i'm i'ma kill that
[__]
i'll kill that [__] right there
i said oh man come on man you know he's
gonna come drunk right now he's kind of
drunk okay okay
he said he said man never do this [__]
again we'll [__] this [__] up i
said
be my [__] guest be my goddamn
man there's nothing wrong with that baby
nothing wrong with it my mother's on
that [__] so
whatever my mother's on it she knows
she's 80 years old what do you think
about 30
30 did you like it oh man you know what
i think that i could i couldn't watch it
come on of course i couldn't watch i i
lived in italy
i lived at what i'm saying i just can't
watch it like that i can't watch myself
you know especially when i'm in an
emotional state because i said you know
i think now since time has changed in my
life
as far as like i'm still doing dennis
rodman that i love my
my little stuff but now it's more like
i've
i'm going back going back in my life
and trying to figure out what went wrong
nothing wouldn't matter i mean i mean
what we're wrong because it's more like
what made you think that went wrong no
it's just it's like
it's like now i'm thinking about all the
things that i thought that was so
[__] bad
and why does it haunt me today why they
hunt you today
yeah why it's hunting me today how's it
hunting you because i'm thinking about
it
well you're allowing yourself to think
about it then if you're gonna put it in
that perspective you're allowing it to
haunt
you want do you want it the haunted i'm
trying not to that's what i'm saying i'm
trying not to but i'm simply just keep
coming back in my face it's okay great
you did this dennis okay great because
in the beginning i was just this
humble [__] [__] coming from
south oak cliff didn't know any better
now i'm just my older guy and i was
going to be in 60
i'm like [__] now so now you know since
i'm not playing basketball i have so
much [__] time on my hands i have
nothing but to think
yeah i'm like [__] i don't want to think
about that [__] but but it
just hits me almost every day you know
i'm trying to find the ways to
occupy my mind so i can focus on the
rest of my life
so you know i've been searching for a
long time so okay great
where am i going i think we all do that
yeah
yeah just don't admit it yeah but we all
do that sometimes
sometimes like one day another day
something happened to me it was nothing
it had nothing to do with my brain
i'm thinking about a feeling and boom
i'm feeling love with my old girlfriend
came on what the [__] was that all about
you know what i mean i did that same
what the [__] was that all about i'm
thinking about this person another
person
what [__] me boom in it but i know it's
not every i know it's [__] uh
it's not reality it's just some feeling
and emotional it doesn't really exist
you know but it took years for me to see
it i would feel that way before i would
get right on the [__] plane
go right to the house i don't care if i
was married i stopped [__] i love you
thinking i love you again
but the next thing you know [__] [__]
what you said what [__]
[__] you was getting out again
my other relationship is dead now it was
going great how all this feeling came up
so i don't
i don't react to my feelings no more i
think this [__] out now
[__] i'm on that plane this is the one
for me [__] that
all right there you go what about you
man you're a football player
yeah man your football player um the
mentality what you have
i mean i had uh coming out i retired in
and i had a moment
probably in uh it was in 2016
where i was haunted by
past actions and um
it felt like i had to
because i'm married i have a daughter
and
i felt as though i had to
there was this demon just coming out of
me that had to come out because i could
no longer
hold on to this information anymore
and i had to come clean with my wife
about who i was and things i'd done to
her
and it was devastating you know it was
devastating especially me
i had no tools for the conversation i
was trying to have with my wife
and you know thank god she's still with
me today man and it's been a long
process
of you know finding forgiveness for
myself
living and amends to my wife who i love
and who has been with me through
you know trips to the hospital [__]
me and my lowest you know
drugs and [__] all kinds of [__]
and you know it's just an absolute
blessing man and you know the truth is
that the past is there
it's not ever going anywhere
and it's our job
to release ourselves from it the best we
can because you know those experiences
they weren't good or bad
we were doing the best we could at the
time with what we had
and so when you come to that
understanding
in yourself you can start to live in the
moment and you can start to live from
this place of
building a new future um and
you know man that was it was the hardest
thing i've ever done in my life
you know having this conversation with
my wife and
i'm so thankful that i did it you know
because she can see me in my truth and
who i
am as a man rather than have some idea
about who she thinks i
am and we can build
on a foundation of true love from there
you know
and it's worked out so far man and it's
one day at a time
you know and uh i mean i totally vibe
with what you're saying dude and
you know i meditate every day i [__]
i have meetings i go to i have a
therapist i
speak to people but i've realized that
there's no escaping yourself
you know no doubt about that like my
mind works a little bit like dennis like
doesn't make it [__] like he's
my mind might get [__] god's gonna get
me home like that [__] i got
i think i got away but i know god's
gonna get me when i die
if i go meet god and heaven father
[__] shouldn't never do that
[__] i'm gonna be [__] you know that's
that could be my ego too thinking god
really cares about me he's gonna really
punish me
like god could ever hear me i was
looking at this camera the other day
and it showed us people right and then
it went it went away and it went
off the planet and showed how small the
planet was and showed how small we were
yeah and showed us how small that
the galaxy was yeah and then it showed
other galaxies bigger than that
yeah another planet is bigger than other
solar systems
and other stars bigger than our stars
yeah and i say to myself
does god even um know we exist how does
god know why
it's my ego playing games with me that
i'm somebody and i'm
nothing well whatever god is it's here
it's all here man and i think that that
because i i totally get what you're
saying man like
and i was i was waking up in the middle
of the night
before those times where i knew i had it
was like a lightning bolt and it was
like you have to
open up to your wife about this and
i realize that you know all of that
is god going to punish me for all of
this
that was all a mechanism of my own
perception
that was keeping me stuck in those
cycles that i was in
you know because at the end of the day
we all have our trials and tribulations
and the things that we've done that
we're ashamed of
and holding on to guilt and it's us
it's on our human this hero journey that
we're on to ascend
past that to transcend those
past actions and that [__] that we hold
over ourselves
yeah yeah it's amazing how you know like
i said i'm a visionary
totally i'm a visionary and um and i
watch uh
iconic figures around the world i don't
read books because you know
i read people and it was it's an honor
just to be in mike's prison because
i think of him sometimes with some of
the icons i think about
and the word existed and i'm like
does mike ever does mike ever
take time out just go to the beach and
just visualize he goes to them just go
to the beach you can have a joint a
[__] blonde what the [__] he smokes
right
right and he's go to the beach and just
sit there and just watch his life in
front of him
and just watch your life in front of him
because my vision is this
this kind of crazy mike you said i'm a
crazy [__] right
that's good so it's like my business
to really break out my cycle and my and
my
my [__] just negativity stuff like
that i was thinking going to john wayne
airport
run a plane get like 10 000 feet in the
air
and dive out the plane no parachute
that was a plane no parachute there's
some [__] okay this is real true
[__]
this true [__] i've been talking about
this for two months and uh
now with the plane and face up to god
and look at everything in my life flash
before me
i'm thinking if that was a [__] god
somebody's gonna [__] put a hand out
there and hold me and say dennis
you got something left for life to for
the world to see
you ain't dying today [__] you
got some more [__]
that you need to approve to the world so
what
um if you're having some
delusions that they're not god or some
complex this is not god if you come here
i can introduce you to something
that would um you'll bet your life that
there's a god after you after using it
i'm all i'm all ears all open baby i'm
all here so i'm all love
i'm all is so you know you got uh you
got to you know
and uh have you tried the toad before
have you ever heard of the toad
it was a toad like a tofu
tofu explain the toe to them all right
uh the toad
man please and it's venom they extract
5meo dmt
and uh it's a sacred medicine ancient
medicine
um thousands of years old and it gives
you
a lot of perspective on your life you
have an experience of god it's
basically everything that you're asking
for this toad
provides see your life
have some perspective you experience an
ego death
you experience dying in some form
you have an experience of god or a
higher power
you're released from a lot of pain and
trauma
um and everyone you know it's uh
mike mike has done it you know i've done
dmt i haven't done the toad yet
but um that's a powerful medicine
dentist's trip that he's on he's you
know yeah you need to figure this out
they're told to give you probably 15 30
years of experience in 20 minutes yep
i tried the uh i tried the uh you know
the aaa
i tried i tried it mike i know the
stories about your a [__] okay
yeah i know i'm sorry about that [__]
right there dennis stannis
just don't try that jumping out of the
plane because ain't no [__] hand
gonna come out and grab you
that's a thought that's a talk it's a
thought don't do it don't try it so you
know so
you're gonna hit the ground real [__]
fast he's gonna grab him one time at the
ground
right i'm just saying someone wants to
hit the ground getting the hands on the
ground
so anyways let's get back to some real
cool [__] about sports
so anyway mike so i'm like i'm an
interviewer uh
so mike let me ask you something like he
said like you said before he's like
basketball was basketball back in the
day like you said my basketball now
what do you think about [__] boxing
it's all political now very political
now and that's why
i think there should be some new
promoters and sometime in the future in
the next couple of months or so
you're gonna find that there's gonna be
some new players in the game and it's
going to be really
serious it would be really awesome
discovery you know
um you know give me your top three boxes
today that you respect today
well i respect tyson fury i respect um
dante weiler i respect all those guys
and andy ruad and stuff
um this guy named lomachenko he's a
[__]
animal master like he's dancing
you know there's quite a bit they got
the guy javonte davis quite a few
fighters that are good fight
but the um what's the situation and are
they going to be able to fight each
other
that's right yeah promoters are not
allowing them to fight each other
they're a great fighter i'd love to see
them fight each other but
the promoters doesn't want to do it you
know i respect it in that in the game
i don't know why i respect this guy just
because he's short i think
but uh pacquiao oh he's
brilliant that [__] about that
he that's probably one of the few
fighters besides you muhammad ali are
you guys in that
haggler and all those guys and stuff
like that that little [__] right there
i never seen that guy back away from
anybody tall
short he he goes and that's like [__] it
okay great and
he's still doing it today i don't know
40 40 years old yeah
close to 50. yeah because so who's the
other guy hopkins
he's a great guy he's a great fighter he
should have retired a long time ago
he's 51 years old i know damn really
yes his last fight is uh he was 51 years
old
b-hub damn wow all right and he still
got his faculty there and
and and he was never cutting his life
yeah
so he never took a lot of punches so
he's he's still in fighting shape today
same weight he walks around he's amazing
so wait wait wait do i see a mike tyson
promotions coming up
oh yeah we're going to work it out
all right only god knows so i mean so i
i think he's curious enough i think he'd
probably never um
address this uh situation he was telling
about uh you had holyfield here
yeah and uh you know i went to my demons
and stuff like that
do you think that fight i was that that
fight
that fight does that ever come come to
fruition
and does it come to your mind if about
that you know they say
well he bit his i didn't give a [__] i
would say [__] are they gonna steal a
fight
do that you think that's one of the
demons in your life that you thought
in boxing i know i never even think
about know what i think about when it
does come i think about um
how much money i made taking pictures of
fighting somebody here
that is supersede the dream
that's what makes it funny to me not
that i bit his ear but that
i made the money i was fine i made that
back and forth
just from taking pictures but biting his
ear can you imagine that
that's how much god in the universe
loves you much isn't that no but that's
just so crazy right when i look at this
are you gonna pay me what and then when
i look up over three years four years
whoa that's how much i made from this
you know yeah that's how i look at it
right dennis
now i wish i learned this earlier but i
teach my children and other people to
younger than me
boom look at us now we're born right now
the certain amount of time till we die
what are we going to do
let's put that out to them we're going
to die
so what are you gonna do we don't know
when but we're gonna die so till then
what we're gonna do let's think right
now i'm gonna get my flip phone okay
i love it i'm gonna get my [__] flip
flops
yeah you know the razors and [__] like
that you know the blueberries the
blackberry what the [__] you calling
right
so it's like so you know but anyway so
let's keep it funny
i've done it i'm sure you've done it
you've done it i know you've done it and
i know you've done it so
right now i've done this twice in my
life
playing sports and i never knew that
this [__] will [__] with you
when you're playing a game i'm trying to
have sex all night before a game
doesn't [__] work out too well
in the first quarter it's like seven
minutes ago i said dennis only talked to
you
now once you take the night off i know
what you did last night you got wheat
knees right yep
take the night off so you go take a
shower and whatever so yeah it ever
happened to you before fire
no i have that but then there's some
people um that if they don't get no
[__] before a fight they can't fight
they [__] up they just can't do it
they have no power right
you've got no power but they don't do
you know one of those times when i did
that in houston i said this girl came
down from [__] detroit you know she's
like you know
and she asked uh she uh we went out to
to a dinner and stuff like that and she
like she looked at me and said you know
what
i got a confession to make and so what
is that she said you know
i never stopped dick before you know
there's a book i can learn how to suck
dick i said
what i said what the [__]
i said oh wow
so dennis i'll just say it right now
like warrior
okay okay you being a very eccentric um
over the top as this you know has
publicity
have you over the top celebrity exotic
celebrity
me myself i knew i had some [__]
experience that people wouldn't believe
did you ever have one experience just
like
you get off the plane and then the
[__] um the plane
what do you call people that works at
the airport there to greet a lady when
you get off the plane to greet you to
the room
or something uh-huh and she may grab you
and greet you right to the [__]
bathroom in that room and you [__] her
or something crazy maybe you ever had
one of those
oh mike come on i'll give you some
[__]
[Laughter]
is
you know you can't you can't even go to
hotels these days now because it's
a lot of not at least don't even
understand this [__] she must not care
if she lost a job
nothing she didn't want a goddamn thing
oh
wow right so this is another level it's
a way to know the level right
it's like when you want to have sex with
a girl now all of a sudden now going
over here
anything is bubbling
here we go here we go right now
well going for it that's like uh
that's such a i mean i don't even know
that's such a high
level of exposure
you know that you're that personality
that people do that
and these videos the [__] should have
got her number right
[__] all about that [__] right here
she's just like
she disappeared yeah they said [__] i
should have got a number she just
de-materialized
whole life i mean
one of i mean i gotta find out
what was it like to go to north korea oh
that thing yeah
kim jong-un bunch of girls in the room
dude i mean talk about the trip don't
that was a trip though man you know um
when they asked me to go to north korea
i was thinking like you know hey man
[__] north korea great i go
stuff like that i'm thinking i'm going
to do an autograph show and play a
basketball game
i didn't know anything about north korea
stupid as [__] right so dennis
you know you're going to north korea i
said yeah i'm going to create what about
it
just be careful so i told my age i said
you know
i i go there knows i'm safe and stuff
like that but it was so cool the fact
that when you get off the plane it's red
carpet
all the dignitaries and everybody's in
suits and that
that's when you walk in you got 80
people around the wall
sitting there i'm sitting in the middle
and uh
they ask you questions and say oh you
happy to be in north korea yep i'm happy
starting it up
so i when i first met him i was playing
with the harlem globetrotters
and uh i wasn't playing until some of
the dictators came down
and i said asked me to go with them i'm
thinking i'm going to jail right or
something [__] like that right and i
said what the [__] did i do in america
you know [__] like that so so i walked
up to the to the bleach up to the
to the stands and sit there in front of
a desk
and these high chairs king chairs and
stuff like that it's like
20 of them so i'm sitting right there um
in the middle
so next thing you know got 22 000 uh
north koreans
all of a sudden they stand up and
celebrate they start clapping
they still clap i mean loud clapping
stuff like that and they're cheering i'm
like you know i think they do it for me
but they turn around and looked at me
like this and i said oh [__] was i
waving
something like that they said no that's
for him i just said for him right they
don't say this for him
i said who is that guy he said that's
our leader i said leader or what
that's a little what he said no he's the
leader of our country
he says kim jong-un i said i have no
clue who the [__] this guy is right
wow so he's already waving doing his
whole you know political stuff stuff
like that he's like
30 years old so he walks over to me
sits down and all of a sudden he's like
put his hand on my
arm he said it's okay then they said
he's waving and people just crying
trying to get to this guy i mean he just
everybody's just crying he's clapping
for like 20 minutes
and all of a sudden everybody sits down
he sits down he starts talking to me
you know in in korean right and
interpreters we had around
he said you like my country i said
that's cool
it's fine it's okay it's okay he said oh
so uh
he said i love basketball i said that's
fine i love it too
he said i'm so glad you're here it's a
fight today and uh
he said something like well we asked
michael jordan to come but he wouldn't
come
so we asked you you know mike i said
hell no i'm not going
so he asked me i'll say yeah i go so
we're sitting there talking about
basketball the whole time this this this
this
shooting the shop stuff like that then
all of a sudden
the game's over i go with him we go into
a room like
70 people around the wall sitting there
like no politicians and [__]
so he's just sitting at dennis we love
you to come back we enjoy your company
so we'll have dinner tonight you know
have a little karaoke
have some [__] vodka you know a
little you know hot totties
and stuff like this so i'll say okay
great next thing that we go to dinner
and we just assume that's shooting this
[__] we're getting drunk and [__] stuff
like that he gets some stuff singing
karaoke have no clue the [__] he's
talking about
so everybody's clapping and he has like
this 18-piece women's band
i mean these [__] girls are [__]
hot hot you know
and the whole time they play one [__]
song
one song it was a [__] thing from
dallas
what the [__] i said what is this all
about right [__]
weird i said thief of dollars he said
that's all we know and stuff like that
and
then i said you know before i left i
said hey man i'm gonna tell you
something here's
seven songs i want you guys to play next
time next time
i come here it's pearl jam live van
halen this is this rolling stones okay
great
go back the next time they played all
those damn songs wow
and then we've been we've been really
good friends after that you know before
the politics
i don't get involved with that i don't
give that so i came here to
to uh bring sports communicate like that
sports
i never talked politics with them i've
seen the military i've seen the muscles
i've seen
every damn damn thing i've seen
everything i've seen i've seen the
muslims and stuff like that
uh they have like three muslims uh three
big
like this about a hundred thousand
square feet
and when you walk in it's like two
hundred thousand people visit the muslim
every day
every day so when you go in the first
name of the father
oh no his grandfather who's a
grandfather so we walk in here it's all
red lights and stuff like the music plan
and the casket the casket is right in
the middle and the lights are shining
right on his grandfather
and people go and like you know you
can't wear glass you can't do this can't
wear
shoes can't wear a hat and stuff like
that so basically go down you bow
and it's actually his grandfather frozen
forever so he said buy himself by
himself so we
we move on we go to the next next room
this is father in the middle of the room
this place is like enormous enormous
they're just right in the room by
themselves
and then after that we move to the next
hall
it's an empty casket for him for him
but does he have a child the other son
yes uh he's a baby girl
and um when she was born i think when i
that's when i went over that she was
only six months old
so i think i first gotta ever do this
you know i had the baby
playing with the baby the whole time you
know doing it gotta drop the baby
no i'm not talking maybe no i'm not
dropping the baby no no no
but anyways so anyway so but it's like i
go to say when i see my baby we all
having a good time
this island he has and um his wife's
there and stuff like that so
i was smart enough to want that i
brought him i brought him up a baby
uh dennis robin jersey we put it on the
baby we took pictures with the babies
stuff like that
but uh it was just so amazing to see
something like that do
and that resonated to me right there
because everyone hates this [__] guy
tell me i want to meet him to tell mike
tyson wants to meet him all right mike
tyson right
fbi new york so
you have to deal with that stuff yeah uh
i think i got a flip phone they track my
calls
so is it like what is the what does it
let you get off the plane there what the
like what does it look like it's like
anything else man
it looks it's like a normal airport you
know you want a private you know
vips part and stuff like that but it was
cool man
the people how do people already are
they [__] starving yeah what are
people like what's that
i didn't see it there's tyranny over
there you didn't see any of that
everything you know when you go to china
hong kong and um
beijing and stuff like that when you
leave the airport you see that
before you get to the you know nice part
you see you see all the [__] poverty
when you go
to these cities you know they don't talk
about [__] like that you go to north
korea oh god damn this guy's gonna kill
this guy this guy go kill this guy
cnn's over there living for [__] 20
years don't know what the [__] they
talking about
you know so i go to that [__] it's like
okay i didn't see that but i see what he
he's doing he's changing the country
he's changing the country you don't see
that point nobody's starving over there
well you know everyone's starved [__]
every every country in the world you're
starving
you know you got homeless people down
there [__] lh skid row
you know so what the [__] i go down and
once a month and i'll go and
shake hands with the [__] and
break bread [__] you know
but you know over there it's probably
different because i didn't see that
i didn't see that part of north korea
like that in depth but i saw everything
else you know you know so it was cool a
good experience and uh and the only
reason why donald trump would not
open the doors it because of me
right here right here right here because
you know what do you have to say to our
president
brother hey donald love your golf
courses love your wife
love your daughter sweet already anyway
hey donald you're doing a good job i
guess i don't know i don't see you too
much these days but hello man whatever
you know so that's that's his he's the
president i don't i don't have anything
to do with
the president i don't have no i have
nothing to do what he does but i like
when we
go out there you know miami should play
golf and shoot this [__] man
you know he's a friend of mine so i like
donal
thomas cool right it's a trip right
so so anyway so how about this though
this question here
after all your accolades mike in the
beginning
and that trainer that loved you so much
right in the beginning yeah
what came in your mind did you have a
wild hair
and said okay this guy made my by my
side from day
one i'm a change
i don't know tell me that i don't know
that's what i'm saying you know
that's that's what i see on tv what you
see on tv you never believe it right
what happened when
i was with my trainee died no no no in
the beginning in the beginning when he
brought you up to what what's one guy
named don't come because
yeah that guy right there right yeah but
he died and then i had somebody else
was that was somebody else was training
me after he died
so did that motivation go away or just
like what whatever
no um it excelled because i wanted to um
win the championship form i wanted to
make him happy i wanted to make him
proud and stuff
that's why that's what's made him got
some pearlescent [__] right here because
it's like
who's that for you um
[Music]
i think you know when chuck did he left
it was like a family to me
that [__] [__] me up because you
know i thought you know once i left
oklahoma
with the rich family in in the country
they told me values about working hard
you know you don't get anything for free
you got to earn it and stuff like that
so when i left those guys
as a family because in the ghetto we
didn't have a bond
we didn't have a bond together it's more
like okay it's all what you know
so when i went to the nba the detroit
piston and truck
they treat me just like that family did
and it
they kept embedding me oh yeah we're
gonna grow this thing together
we're gonna be a family we're gonna you
know do this together stuff like
more like that and uh we was together
for like five years straight i mean
24 7 pretty much to win a championship
yeah
and then next thing you know he he left
and then i just lost it
i started i just like just [__] lost
i said what the [__] am i gonna do now
you know there was nobody there for me
my wife took my kid
she [__] [__] [__] [__] took my
[__] kid
she took where i got that money she did
that she tried to cross the country in
the [__] dead winner
i had to call the [__] state [__]
highway patrol all around the world to
find my [__] baby
they caught her [__] ass they put her
snj i put my kid in [__] foster care
or some [__]
then they said i'm hearing all that and
i got this problem over here
and i'm gonna go commit suicide and i
don't know what [__] i'm at and
then i'm all lost the next thing you
know they traded me
to san antonio then my whole life
perspective changed completely
i forgot the fact that damn
were you happy there uh i think i had no
conscience
because i was just pretty much numb i
was just pretty much numb at the point
[__] everybody [__] this [__] this [__]
that i'm gonna go out there and play
but i never left i never lost that
compassion and that heart that drive
to go out to do my [__] job you know
when when rebound titles in
detroit having all the [__]
destruction and that all that [__] that
this coming to san antonio
go to san antonio go win a rebound title
there
first year boom kept my focus on
[__] right
out all the [__] boom the next ship
won the rebound title i almost go to the
nba finals
and thank you for that sending told me
to make it then next thing you know i
get traded the guy from chicago
straight up a [__] will badou of all
[__] people
whip would do and then my life just
exploded from that point on i'm like yes
that's so great
now my life i made a whole
three three three sixty [__] flip
when i went to chicago then all of a
sudden now
i felt loved again because people saw
that work ethic i had it was just not
but just go out there and go
do what you have what it takes to
[__] win and those people you know
about this
they love you and they love it when you
compassionate about doing one thing
going on to win win
and make people happy that was my whole
thing to change my whole [__] around
right there
amazing right so how old were you when
you started playing basketball
22. wow really
22. so you weren't out there as a kid i
don't know man
[__] i didn't i don't think i started
[__] until like 22.
i i had to [__] one day wick uh i had
to come one day and
the girl upstairs she's like oh wait i
had to [__] her i didn't think you know
anything about that [__]
some of the great you know very rare but
like marciano and larry home they
started late
look what happened to them yeah
interesting what do you think about that
mike because i've always thought about
that maybe that
when you come into it a little later
you've got more energy for it
no um i'm gonna say what custom models
say
it's not um the styling you wanna use or
the age of the person his morality
his determination to win it's you know i
mean
his what's that go internal fortitude
his desire to be somebody his urge to be
greater than what he is then to have
that you could be any age
it doesn't matter yeah yeah doesn't
matter so anyway so mike i'm gonna ask
you something
i want you to ask me the same question
i know your kids are pretty much just
like my kids my kids my soul survivor of
anything
in the world what is your
motivation my motivation
the urge to improve myself
it's all about me has nothing to do with
my children they're not like me they
don't belong to me you know i mean
they belong to the world the world's
gonna do to them what
what it did to me and my job is to
prepare them for that
pain mine is mine's
more like trying to find out who the
[__] i am and try to be happy
that's interesting that's my goddamn
thing right there i've lived the glam in
the glam and all that [__] it's my
motivation to do one thing keep my head
[__] positive some ways some [__]
house keep my goddamn ass positive
instead of trying to go to that dark
place and say that [__] ain't work [__]
anymore because you had every
[__] thing no i got to keep myself
positive and try to keep myself happy
because about what you think
what is everything you know i didn't
think i had nothing you know at first
i think everything was nothing after
i've i've been with every woman i had
every drug every
expensive champagne every expensive
hotel room in the world every expensive
boat every plane and then i just
told them realized i didn't have nothing
i never seen anything
that's amazing it's amazing for all
these youth today they should get they
should get this uh
life experience because you know what
[__] like me mike and
mew and chuck this is three different
elements here
there's three different elements and
people understand kids that they
want everything right [__] now they
don't want to think about it they want
to do a goddamn thing
everything's going to come come come but
i'm saying if you if
kids are uh listening to guys like us
we're not trying to tell you what the
[__] they do we're just saying
take time out to understand what you're
[__] doing okay
[__] do that [__] okay it's gonna be
impossible
for the kids to listen to us you know
it's an impossible listen
it's almost impossible because when you
think about yourself as a kid
like myself i look at myself i always
looked up to people because i've learned
from an older man
as a little kid you know but before i
met cus nobody could tell me
[__] i'm 10 years old 11 years old and
stuff
i got 3 000 in my pocket your father
don't got three dollars your rent don't
cost three thousand
[__] dollars i got jury i got [__]
you got a motive a moped and stuff
like you told me something that's just
what it was
and um was it did you start listening to
cuss
when you experienced his advice working
for you in the ring
that too but he has demanded respect he
demanded i wanted to be
a social i wanted to be his friend i
wanted to be around him
you know i mean i wanted him to like me
it's the way he conducted himself nobody
[__] with him
i respected him the police the firemen
everybody
you're tired you know how that [__]
works right you know how i was struck
right
yes so that's what it was right and one
day he couldn't he even knows how i
think before i even say it
he knows something comfortable around
those white people so one day he told
everybody
i mean see this black kid right here
this he's one of us he's part of the
family now
when he said that i knew [__] i was i
had it made i can get away with anything
like that i was the guy my whole
my whole journey in life was to make him
happy that's my whole purpose
right so anyway so since we don't want
to
say something about your life chuck what
the [__] nobody's talking about come on
chuck no one knows too much about you
you know you're saying time to reflect i
mean i did six years in prison
so every day i was reflecting every
every
how far back i could go as a little kid
you know so it's uh one thing your
family was always there for you
and that's what i uh learned you know
friends come and go but your family's
there you know because i know i know
chuck i knew you hate talking about this
[__] but we we uh we always break break
when we see each other
and stuff like that and we always and
one thing we always talk about you know
uh we talk about you know how's your
daughter
absolutely i always ask you all the time
because i
i told everybody every time you saw me
you always ask how my family was
right and that's the thing yeah we we
get older
and we don't realize then but even then
i [__] up
you know i was with the club the whole
time every father's day i was up in
laconia with the club instead of being
my
my family my daughter my wife
and i lost them both i mean uh you know
they're still here i mean i didn't lose
them but right
uh uh i could have been a better father
like we all could have been oh yeah big
time we get older
and we realized how we [__] up right
and especially me going to jail for six
years i [__] up
right and not only was i enjoying my
whole family was in jail with me so
you know it's uh because they always
came to visit me they were you know it
was a hardship for them
but uh at the end you know i came back
and uh
but like you said we could have been a
better father
right better folks
and we uh uh wait till we're too late
when we're rolled
right you know now we're here talking
about it never too late
never too late never too late right but
we're here to talk about it because
you know what i didn't think you think
you'd make 30 or 40 or 50.
all right this stuff we've been through
all right i'm 66 i never thought i'd see
or the stuff i've been through with the
club and everything else and on the
streets
listen i've tried to kill myself for so
many years i realized that it didn't
work
can we talk about [__] chuck is 66.
oh man he looks good don't you got that
looks [__]
great all right put it right here man
look at this guys
yeah well those are the keyboard
warriors i never say it to my face
it's amazing you get all these guys with
keyboard warriors talk [__] on the
internet right but when you're out there
doing a signing somewhere when you're
all over the place
not one guy comes up to you oh yeah
that's amazing right
you talk some good [__] that sometimes
i go to arnold classic every year in
columbus ohio 300 000 people there
not one guy says boo to me but on a
keyboard you know these guys these
warriors
and especially one jerk off always
talking [__] i said
please please meet me before i die
i gotta be able to break your jaw i
wouldn't even give him a satisfaction
just some scumbag that's on the keyboard
talking about me and hell's angels all
the time
but i tell meet me here meet me i'll
never ever ever do it
all right talk [__] before i die
please meet me i want to break your
[__] jaw all right
if he's listening he knows who he is
you're punk no
i'm sorry anyway michael hey mike you
might like get this [__] out the way
go for it that's what we can you know so
anyway
so my super agent right there that guy
right there during prince
he got this thing right here the book
right here
right there right there come on come on
right look at that don't look at that
[__] speech today
right i got your book right there
you damn your aim oh yeah yeah oh let go
and let god right yeah yeah yeah
one day at a time there you go there it
is
hey man hi right you gotta mention in a
photo in there yeah eleven and a half
years sober from opiates
oh man that was the best thing i've ever
done in my life congratulations
thanks brother that's really nice
oh long time this guy right we all do
what we all do the best thing ever
happened to me right
that i got involved with aaa that got
introduced to aaa i met some of the most
amazing people in the world still my
friend to this day
there you go mike tyson right there guys
that is right there
and dennis yeah a couple years ago in
new york
right right there that's awesome man
dennis has been he comes
once in a while he's like the spiritual
messages yeah
so it's all good so now we got a little
history with darren right there now so
there got all the photos with magic and
everybody got iconic photos man
yeah joe frazier joe frazier muhammad
ali everybody yeah
talking [__] talking [__]
hey talking [__] to the day they die
they were talking [__] right
he's exhausted that's exhausting he let
he let it go a little bit in the end
he let it go but it was the public that
would remind him constantly because that
was such a private dinner that nobody
knew about
and every time they just dig at him you
know he would just have to engage
every time they'd have to engage all
right you guys
got your aim in high [__] out the way
right yeah
look at that from there baby yeah hi
baby
he's got the forward by magic there you
go all right there you go
so i got my boy that big wheel that
guy's been around me for a long goddamn
time
he went to prison so anyway so yeah i
got that guy
i got a lot of people out there so i got
uh got there's a
nourish right here i'm doing right now
with cbd like you doing yes i got
nourished right now you know for floors
and stuff like that so
cbd is right there guys you want to pick
it up you know so it's all good it's
awesome it's right there man straight up
straight up all good i'm gonna throw one
down
one down right don't go on down the path
show everybody there man so you know
so in connection with floors so baby
so anyway so i got the and my partner
right now you know
he has his car so it's called black cars
maybe take one of those
let me take one out yeah that's a little
quiet here you want to try a couple
yeah give me one of those give me one of
those damn things there you go
[__] that's a pretty goddamn good man
[__] ain't really got them good
i got the pen for you mike right there
you want the pen yeah right there
right there oh you got the paper
a lot of goodie bags you know a lot of
goodie bags for my friends said you know
it's all good
so anyway so i got one more plug man
either way i got two more players anyway
so anyway so i'm always plugging [__] i
never do this [__] but anyways
i got my new line coming out it's called
love ugly we ever talked about that
love ugly coming out love love this ugly
baby
to each its own but anyway it's coming
out in a couple weeks so
check it out guys cuz love it i live
because love doesn't care how you look
that's what i'm saying there it is that
is right there so me and bobby
man bobby you out there looking baby
baby yeah
it's gonna take a solo
those [__] right some other board my
other boys there i
have the boy with the cars and [__]
black cars got little servers all around
the country
you know mike and i tie those guys they
got some water coming out ph water right
here for you guys man
check it out yeah right here you guys
want to check that out right there
you know so it's called quilt i drank a
bottle that's his daughter's name on
on the table for taylor right beautiful
that's his daughter right there so they
got the food that's what tastes good
energizing stuff right there take some
take some of our doings we have done
i got to have
i've been drinking the whole time i've
been here i said [__] so it's all good
hell yeah this is good that's a hell of
a name though you wait that's dwayne
do you have any um [__] um what are
the charities or anything
no my whole thing about my charity i
never got into a charity i always
do like to you know behind the scenes
beautiful charity foundation
how many people respect you and be
involved to help you
devote yourself to something like that
so the one thing that i came up with
since i joined this company
um i came with this uh idea of the fact
that
i'm so i'm so connected with the
homeless
you know i'm so connected with them i
was thinking that i've
talked to the guys that they flourish i
want to go down
once a month to go down and try to just
connect with the
i said my people and just give them like
some cbds
some things to try to try to enhance
them to try to you know borderline what
they're doing now
and try this and just try it and see if
they can help them
you got to do it that's what i'm saying
i'm going to go to skid row down in l.a
i'm going to do it in dallas i'm going
to do it in vegas i'm going to do it in
new york
i'm just going to walk when i'm like my
crew and everybody's going to pass them
out
and just you know it's beautiful because
you know it's it's kind of bad when you
see homeless people i don't care how you
look at it
you know it's kind of bad and stuff like
that so that's what we're going to be
doing right we're nursing stuff like
that so i'm behind it 100
if it's all about the money for me it's
not about the money i want to see people
happy i'm not going to show how you want
it how you get it go get it
so that's my whole thing man that's my
whole campaign right there for the rest
of my life
to try to make everything pure and happy
if it's not pure
try to make it wait it makes sense to
you it's awesome it makes sense to you
so
i'm just glad to be here man to see this
[__] guy he's in my goddamn
neighborhood man
didn't even tell me this [__] baby
he told me he told me to lay he said
goddamn man at the at the pump brothers
event yeah he said man let me tell you
something dennis oh
thank god i got the [__] out of the l.a
it's too [__] crazy here man i said
really go to
that i'm in newport and i said you got
you've got your head straight on now man
now all the beaches and [__] all the
time so chill like that
worry about running the people i don't
want to see right yeah no [__] bro you
get to watch that hide right get rid of
them once they see you
right it's cool so you know people right
when you can't get rid of
them right but anyway so in fact how's
your [__] going
how's this stuff this whole uh um tyson
wrench going on beautifully
um taste is in the pudding
okay that's a good right it's all yeah
so baby that's
you know i said about my my product
right here it's coming out pretty good
man
i call it gsd get [__]
done you know get it done got to get it
done goddamn get [__] done
[__] it right those gummies are awesome
they're all awesome right
great so anyway so i'm i got a lot of
[__] to do today man what do you have to
do
what's next what's next you need to be
more movies
no no no definitely i just got an
[Music]
that guy van damme that's a cocky little
[__] right there man
you know hey oh hey this uh you know
about this story right oh yeah they have
a story
i think everybody knows legendary right
there legendary so that's legendary
right so i'm the guy who told me that
yeah yeah that's when he came up and he
said what the [__] you're sitting with
this guy for us what are you talking
about
he was just talking bad about you in the
bathroom i said come on man don't start
no [__]
but it was that believe it or not was 22
years ago
and people still ask me every day about
that
right but we're friends now so i don't
talk about it no more we're friends two
years after you die you're gonna be in a
[__] book yeah
absolutely absolutely and don't forget
did you see the uh
30 for 30. his documentary it's awesome
you know dennis is uh dennis rodman this
is 30
30. right for better for worse
so you know what we should we man mike
we should do something just me and you
tell me about it right now
we should literally seriously we should
literally
just me and you it could be on a boat it
could be in a car we should go somewhere
for a weekend just me and you and break
bread
i mean just literally break bread about
our lives nah [__] we gotta go help
people man that's what i'm saying
we're gonna get about helping people
understand we gotta get out of here it's
clear
when i get out of here clear first guys
can do something for the homeless
together
right project you're talking about with
the homeless right mike wants to do
stuff for the homeless
i think that's awesome yeah get homeless
we should collab with that definitely
when we go to skid row with me
let's collab with that just go down and
hang out for the [__] day right let's
do it man [__] [__] do it i'm all
about it man go down the empty hand and
[__]
you can't go empty handed for the [__]
[__] toys kick
it just like i said dude this this is
like refreshing it's a beautiful day out
here in el segundo
yeah we're gonna head off i'm gonna head
back to newport i got another meeting
but guess what it's a [__] nuts man
you know living life like this
feeling free your whole soul
that's what i'm saying always man so
dennis thank you so much man
you want anybody to know anything dennis
want to tell anybody anything
well i'm trying to get to you mom but um
it's taking me a hard time to try to
reach my my goal is to try to
better myself and be up be a young uh
a person to respect you that's what i
want to do right there
awesome that sounds pretty cool right
though amazing brother thank you so much
for joining us oh man
anytime at any time man awesome to come
back
you're welcome here anyway chuck chuck's
hanging out [__]
chuck any closing words man thank you so
much where's the wisdom chuck
no not just to be with these two legends
in the room and you also
damn i'm surrounded by uh icons here
i'm uh i'm proud man i'm happy i'm
happy to be alive and uh every day is a
gift man you gotta remember that yeah
thursday's a gift we woke up again today
wake up you wake up in the morning it's
a good start a lot of people don't
okay so i'm just happy to be here and we
go back a long time myself and mike and
also dennis we go back
[__] 30 years wow all right maybe more
alright so
i was at mike's but you know when uh his
first pro fight is professional debut
actually one of our guys he used elle's
angel john the baptist was the
main event and you wanted the other card
man and kevin rooney was a co-main event
yeah he was my trainer absolutely
absolutely
absolutely right so i was there that
first night and saw you see
we said who the [__] is this guy
[Laughter]
it lasted like five seconds
so anyway so i think everybody knows
about the uh about the uh
the incident that happened to earn mike
tyson
he's just indestructible this [__]
fool right here
has to go home and be dad and get on
that [__]
i had to get a back surgery
it's tough to come from the back surgery
right yeah to come back from the back
side just tough man you know
yeah [__] because every now and then i
feel it oh i gotta loosen up
terry you know the hulkster had nine
back surgeries nine
he's no good then oh yeah it can't be
anything right he could all you know
he can't defend himself oh no [__] right
now come on [__] the wind come hurt us
oh those operations
you know what i always say when he was
on rocky you know rocky iii
as thunder lips he brought wrestling
back i always said that
and i got to say one thing about uh
dennis right here he was the first guy
in sports to have tattoos and everybody
copied them
because not everybody has [__]
tattoos and sports and every kind of
sports whether it's baseball football
boxing mma everybody has tattoos but you
were the first i always say that
yep so it's all good chuck you know
chuck i was ignorant
absolutely the first the first time i
met this [__] [__] kill my [__]
ass dude
oh we're talking about that when i first
met oh my god who is this [__] guy
i didn't know who the [__] he was you
know so tell that story chuck
well we're in uh madonna's i think uh
restaurant or whatever that i was down
the city right yeah
and i was sitting with one of your exes
this [__] guy
and she goes well that's dennis i used
to go with him and then he's he's
calling me over he wants to go you ain't
going nowhere you're sitting right the
[__] here
and you had two guys with you it was
funny it was funny right so it was funny
so
we became best friends after that after
that yep
of course like i said i'm just happy to
be here so with three icons in this room
here man
so it's gonna happen good man so
i'm in town on you know
come to the house or whatever i'm
getting a plane soon that leave here
where you hit it where are you going
new york i'll be in new york yeah i'm
going to new york for two or three days
and then we're
going we're going to miami then miami
antigua you've been antiquated miami
yeah when are you going to miami what
day um oh yeah you'll be gone all next
week one day yeah
yeah when you go to miami i'll be at
miami uh i'll be in miami friday
yeah thursday friday we're going for
this each other's
um try to put tyson ranch what we
already do we have a tyson ranch in
antigua
yeah right yeah i'll see how it looks
yeah we should we we should collapse
some on some things man
one day that's something what do you
think
so there's a piece of the world back
back in the world right put some pieces
back and you know we gotta put you in
movies man we got movies
no i mean you know that's like chuck
said man the tattoos thing you inspired
a generation of athletes to be
themselves
right you know because sports in this
country can be such a little container
right for personalities you know and
people can get
bogged down in the prism of being an
athlete
and being this on this platform
as a hero to young kids the youth of
america
it's like man these kids should be
understanding that you can be an athlete
and express your truth as well you know
so
can i see that water again the water
drink the
quilt equip yeah right here so let you
guys know what yeah this great warning
pretty good my ph right so he's one of
the few black guys that live in newport
beach besides me and this kid over here
so anyway
one of the few black guys that's very
entrepreneur he's doing his own thing
got a little more services car service
and plane and stuff like that give's got
a try right it's quail quail water man
coil water give them a try
it's all good man it's really good
that's all good
well [__] man i'll i'll bring us out
mike
let's do it there you go amazing episode
thank you brother dennis
thank you thank you brother this is big
brother this is big this is big
really blessed there you go some [__]
that's the eagle's about to take flight
right there you go sleep i'm gonna sleep
all right y'all man thanks for tuning in
to this very special episode of hot
boxing
we are out of here get the ccd product
get the city free
product right there newest from flourish
there you go right there baby look it up
look it up
awesome there it is right there all
right guys peace
[Music]
two